here's probably my most important night  of the question of the night sir  did you study floyd mayweather on  Dancing with the Stars no III didn't see  I heard he was on the show but I didn't  I didn't shake it out  yeah I doubt he was any good though you  know it's interesting Justin Bieber came  to your defense and said Floyd  Mayweather will not knock you out does  it give you comfort that Justin Bieber's  in your corner yeah well all you gotta  do is look at this statistics Floyd has  knocked anyone out in like 20 plus years  so there you go Justin's on the ball  with that one I'm feeling pretty  confident that I can walk through any  shot and break him down  you